jabulanim kizi sits alongside the body
of his 19 year old daughter
her body was discovered after she was
washed away by flood waters in hernandez
outside the port city of durban
they still haven't found her sister
who's been missing for two days
what happened to our family is
devastating i've lost two of my
daughters my other daughter and wife are
in hospital and the worst part is that
we have not received any help from the
government the only help we have is from
the community
is leading the search for missing people
after heavy rain and mudslides
devastated this region of south africa
as they walk through the steep hills
that force the torrents of water through
the village
she says this is where the first body
was found at least five other people
from this community are missing
throughout ananda the destruction only
worsens roads and bridges have collapsed
cutting of people from main roads
there's no electricity or running water
here at least four homes have been
reduced to rubble
we heard people shouting my brother and
father tried to rescue them but by then
the houses were covered by water and the
tree collapsed on the houses we don't
know what happened to them people here
say they can't do much to find those who
are missing
while president sular mapos has visited
some of the flood-stricken areas and
offered government support this
community says there's not been any so
far
informal settlements have been severely
affected by the heavy rain and flooding
while the rain has slowed for now it's
expected to get worse people who escape
the first wave of flooding are worried
they'll not be as fortunate in the
coming days familia miller al jazeera
durban south africa